I've just received a call from Secretary
Clinton she congratulated us it's about
us on our victory and I congratulated
her and her family on a very very
hard-fought campaign I mean she she
fought very hard Hillary has worked very
long and very hard over a long period of
time and we owe her a major debt of
gratitude for her service to our country
I mean that very sincerely now it's time
for America to bind the wounds of
division have to get together to all
Republicans and Democrats and
independents across this nation I say it
is time for us to come together as one
United people style
I pledge to every citizen of our land
that I will be president for all
Americans and this is so important to me
for those who have chosen not to support
me in the past of which there were a few
people I'm reaching out to you for your
guidance and your help so that we can
work together and unify our great
country as I've said from the beginning
ours was not a campaign but rather an
incredible and great movement made up of
millions of hard-working men and women
who love their country and want a better
brighter future for themselves and for
their family